Mr tiing Professor
guring dear members of the German
bundestag and uh the city assembly of
Hamburg I must salute to vice president
Andre
trepo representatives of the church the
chambers the
associations The Diplomatic
Corp and uh dear ladies and
gentlemen long before our European Union
was
born the citizens of Hamburg were living
with European
values breathing the air of democracy so
to speak shaping the future of their
city and taking responsibility for the
common good we see that today in the
example of Stefan rimers who has always
taken action on behalf of the weakest
and neediest among us we see
it in the case of Angela
bulut it was impressive how she
described the table they have
uh in their part of the city and of
course we saw it in the case of Mrs
lanstein candle and her commitment to
the defense of uh Jewish life and mutual
understanding between religions uh
I must uh thank you all three from the
depth of my heart uh you are an amazing
inspiration to us
all we stand at the beginning of a
crucial
year it is the greatest election year in
history more than half of humanity
over 4 billion people will be called to
the ballot boxes this year not just in
Europe in India Indonesia South Africa
there will be elections as we know there
will be elections in the USA as well and
in many other countries uh big and small
people will be deciding on their
futures of course it's been some years
now that we have been concerned over
trends that put our Democratic Society
is under
pressure we experience uh
now the reality that we have to do more
more than turn up at The Ballot Box
every four or five years the times are
such that on a daytoday basis we must uh
all stand up for our democracy and
values to stress this point I'd like to
mention three
dates the 24th of February
2022 the 7th of October
2023 and the 25th of November
2023 on the 24th of February 2022
Putin's tanks rolled over the Ukrainian
border on the 7th of
October Hamas terrorists attacked
Israeli Villages and carried out the
worst mass murder of Jews since the
shower men women and children babies
were slaughtered merely because they
were
Jewish and uh we have seen open hatred
of Jews break out on our
streets some days ago we learned from
the press that on the 25th of November
far right politicians and activists met
met in a villa in
Potsdam there they discussed plans for
the expansion of millions from Germany
and
Europe the symbolism of this was a
wakeup call and hundreds of
thousands demonstrated against these
ideas in the streets last
weekend thank
goodness
clearly something has changed
imperceptibly insidiously in the last
few years something that perhaps in
retrospect May a few years from now
appear as a deep cultural and political
change we who are in the midst of it
have not perhaps yet quite realized what
is
happening all the three events that I me
mentioned though involved distressing
the distressing breaking of taboos few
of us thought it possible but these
events
occurred for decades we could be
confident in Europe that the borders of
sovereign states and international law
actually
mattered we were also confident that we
would never again see deadly violence on
this SC directed at Jewish
people and most of us also thought it
impossible that here we would see
serious plans to deny
minorities I speak of people with German
passports would be denied the right to
remain on mass only because they have a
different cultural or religious
background what on Earth has gone wrong
what can we do about
it naturally this question is addressed
first and foremost to
politicians they must come out with a
clear
unequivocal and strong
message Putin is an aggressor and
responsible for war
crimes his strategic objective
was to take KF within a few days
and then take Europe hostage due to its
dependency on Russian
gas well he came up against the courage
and resistance of the ukrainians but
also the unity of Europe and its
partners and he must continue to fail if
we are to live safely in Europe and if
Ukraine is to have a future in Europe as
a free country
country Hamas is a terrorist
organization we must stand up for the
protection of Jewish life on our streets
and the right of Israel to
exist independently of the basic
obligation to defend C ion
lives there is no contradiction
there what we have learned from the
far-right machinations in The Villa in
potam is
intolerable the attitudes behind uh
those
mations is cynical or cynical and
inhumane earlier this this week the
leader of the afd Parliamentary group
called for the Germany to leave the EU
to leave a Europe that has brought us 70
years of peace freedom and
prosperity she wants uh to go back to a
past that never really existed how
unaware of history and how blind to the
Future can one
be
debates on the Right Way Forward are an
integral part of democracy and to be
sure Europe is far from perfect when you
have 27 States 450 million people coming
together there will be things which
don't work and which we have to work on
further but that should not
obscure
our view of what Europe is achieving our
European Union is one of the most
prosperous and socially Progressive
regions of the
world no party has more trade agreements
with other economic blocks and no member
State profits more from the internal
Market than Germany we must decisively
counter those who count on anger hatred
and the erosion of our sense of
community we must do this at National
level at European level and
international level because Putin and
the dividers in our societies have one
thing in
common democracy stands in their
way and they contribute nothing nothing
at all to tackling the real challenges
of our
age
digitalization
climate change competitiveness
demographics
migration just to mention a
few on the contrary Putin purposely
exploits soft
spots to weaken our
democracies you will still remember I'm
sure that last winter he systematically
depleted our gas
supplies and then limited energy product
experts country by country to
Europe prices of course Rose tfold we
had a serious energy crisis those prices
are back now to their level before the
war and Putin's state sponsored trolling
factories and his cyber attacks on
Democratic elections and institutions
like the bundestag are
notorious because he knows that it
Fosters fear Among
Us it is our task on the one hand to
counter those who ped pedal fear with
facts and on the other side of course
people's voices must be heard the pace
of digitalization or global warming or
globalization is challenging to people
it's all going so very
fast but that is why we have to show
every day that our social market economy
can help people to manage the pressure
of
change and to show people that democracy
has the best answers we can do
that think only of the pandemic torch
lit processions barriers tinfoil hats
they help nothing they help no one when
it comes to viruses we've got got a
continent of 450 people successfully
through a very difficult time and I
think when you look back that we can be
a little proud proud that we managed
to that member states big and small
progressed
together that everyone obtained uh
vaccines uh in one go it's hard to
imagine that our internal Market
remained intact and that we were the
only major vaccine producers who
remained open for the rest of the
world the US shut down India shut down
they produ were producers but they had
to shut down for the outside world we
did not
uh and uh that is something that will
never be
forgotten it was a wonderful
achievement
it is another big step forward that uh
at European level we will now after 10
long years of
negotiation finally have better rules on
migration and
Asylum I would like to be Crystal
Clear we have always fulfilled our
International commitments and
obligations in the past and we are doing
so today
and we will also do so in future but it
is for us Europeans to decide who comes
here and under what conditions it is not
for the traffickers and Smugglers and
certainly not for autocratic rulers to
make those
decisions equally as we all know and you
know it better than most we need more
legal and safe ways into Europe the
principle must be that those with skills
and the prospect of a job should not
have to entrust their savings let alone
their lives to
criminals I know that many of you are
desperate for skilled labor it would
mean you could take on more orders you
could expand your
business so what has succeeded in the US
and Canada via legal migration must must
contribute to growth and prosperity here
too I would like to cite another example
of European success we have overcome an
energy crisis we have weaned ourselves
from Russian oil coal and pipeline gas
for the first time last year we produced
more electricity from wind and Sun than
Le from
gas these renewable energy sources are
not just good for the climate they're
also good for our
independence they're
homegrown and in the bigger picture too
the trend is moving away from the old
dirty Technologies to cleaner processes
and products look at what the US is
doing they are powerfully investing in
cleaner Technologies via their inflation
reduction
act $340
billion China is massively subsidizing
electric vehicles the Gulf States which
have endless supplies of oil and gas are
now concentrating on clean hydrogen why
well they tell me that they dominate
energy markets today and they want to do
that tomorrow in future as well and they
know that clean hydrogen will be
dominant in future so they're investing
in
it Europe leads in the field uh leads
the field in terms of clean hydrogen
patents we now draw more investment to
in clean hydrogen than the US and China
put together we are leaders in Wind
offshore wind power and Europe leads on
Smart power
networks which are absolutely necessary
to adapt to clean energy this is where
the wind blows here is the natural home
of energy intensive industry and here we
will soon have the infrastructure to
import hydrogen from all over the world
and I can assure you at the European
level we are doing
everything possible to make sure that
Europe and therefore Hamburg as well
remains number one on this young growth
Market
it shows that democracy
delivers ladies and gentlemen I
need hardly tell the citizens of Hamburg
that our world is driven by economic
interests Innovation and functioning
markets that is why competitiveness is
so important to our businesses but it's
not
everything I am more convinced than ever
that democracy itself is our greatest
Home
Advantage politicians must lead they
must clearly point the way
forward but it is only with our
economy's investment power the
innovation of our medium-sized
businesses that we will curb global
warming it is only with clear rules that
we can develop in artificial
intelligence so that it serves people
and not the other way around that means
that politicians must create the
framework but it will always be the
people the citizens who give democracy
life it will be their input that forms
the backbone of our
democracy it was a joy to see how many
people here in Hamburg went out to
demonstrate last weekend for our
democratic values
that so many businesses are also
standing up for those values citizens
are clearly aware of their rights but
also aware of their responsibility for
the common good that was wonderful and
impressive and I'm grateful for
it when in June citizens in 27 member
states vote in European elections it
will be a moment of renewal for the
Democratic foundations of our Union a
moment to consider what really matters
to us one can of course do business
everywhere but where people want to live
and bring up their
children well that is where the streets
are safe that is where there are
prospects for
people where everyone has access to
education and culture regardless of
income it's where lasting peace Reigns
it is where everyone has access to
health care where people can move freely
study and work where there are no longer
borders where if you build something up
it remains yours
where the law
rules and not
despotism that is what the citizens
prize stands for and that is what the
European Union stands for and it is
worth standing up for those values with
everything we've got let's make Europe
strong together thank you so
much
the
[Music]
for